just curious how many people are using
machine learning already in the room
okay a few how many of you are using
deep learning already
how many interested in getting into deep
learning alright a lot more hands cool
okay so some information about me I'm a
Google developer expert for machine
learning and deep learning
I'm co-organizer of it since float
meetup in Singapore
based in Singapore most the time I I
spend pretty much all my time working on
stuff to do with deep learning a lot of
it to do with language and dialogue I
and so actually my co-founder I had a
paper at nips conference which is a big
machine learning conference last year
about this and we're currently working a
lot on natural voices so this is where
we will see if it works so I'm very
pleased to be at fast Asia with you
today I hope you will enjoy the talk
from one of my creators this afternoon
and that you will start your journey in
deep learning so this is a voice that
we're currently prototyping that's built
all entirely with neural networks
well basically like a neural network it
uses deep learning for the whole the
whole thing I and it's I it's built on
training data and then you can basically
you can just read English and then speak
it straight away I very different than
the sort of probably what you've heard
of like the phoneme systems and stuff
like that okay so let me get started I I
mean a lot of people who ask me
questions the questions I get a lot of
things like I you know what is the best
way to learn deep learning what's the
fastest what's the easiest what's the
most efficient I do I need to know math
I can't you know can I just write it in
the current language the programming
language that I already know that kind
of stuff um and I get these questions
really regularly so my response ends up
being questions back and the questions I
asked back I was okay well what do you
want to use deep learning for I and what
do you want to do with it what do you
know how much of it you want to know how
deep you want to go how much you want to
learn I what you already know and then
also sort of where you plan to use these
skills so I'm in the lucky position now
that I've seen a lot of people learn
deep learning through teaching them and
also just through
people friends learning and stuff with
that I've kind of seen what works what
doesn't I so I want to go through some
of those things today and then maybe
even get you started by teaching you
some of the sort of key concepts to
understand this stuff I'll say that it's
not hard right everyone sort of looks at
at people in deep learning and stuff
like that as oh wow you know you're like
you've got this amazing ability but for
the majority of things it's gonna be you
know quite simple free to get started
and probably to build projects so goals
you know I think if you're gonna learn
something like deep learning you need to
have some core goals for yourself you
need to have something that you want to
build so everyone in here is a coder is
that correct yeah anyone not a coder
okay a few people the most mostly coders
in the room okay I so the deep the deep
learning field itself is so big that you
know I could just talk for a whole day
on and not even finish all the different
types of models that are out there I so
you've got to be very specific when
you're gonna go into this about what it
is that you want to achieve what is it
that you want to learn um the other
thing I want to sort of get across today
is that don't be stopped by you know
sort of hitting roadblocks of where you
don't understand certain things deep
learning education is still extremely
new that said in the last year there's a
hell of a lot of new things have come
out and it's getting easier every day
there's lots more tutorials that kind of
thing so my goal for the talk is to
basically give you a ten thousand foot
view then go into some of the key
concepts and and show you some key
resources for this kind of thing I when
I talk about sort of you know learning
deep learning I think of deep learning
as sort of three levels of proficiency
the first being sort of just and this is
even I sort of step above you know what
the the IOT speaker Marco was talking
about he's talking about using pre-made
models and you know any any developer
should be able to do that quite easily
it's just paying an API but you can very
quickly also build your own sort of very
simple models without customizing them
that much to make your own api's and I
think that's one of the first levels of
the
you want to be able to get to the second
is being able to customize things and
the first that was extremely easy
the second is basically customizing
things now where you understand a little
bit of how deep learning works and
you're trying to make it fit your
particular situation this is yes more
challenging but it is definitely still
very easy to do the third level is
basically sort of where you're creating
techniques and methods for new kinds of
data and problems this is very very
difficult to do all right this is what I
spend hours sort of you know working out
trying to get you know voices sounding
more natural or get you know certain
algorithms to work better so first off
what what is deep learning well the
media thinks that deep learning is this
you know they seem to think that it's
sort of like Terminator meets you know
some sort of oppression system that's
gonna take over the world
I find that uh most people when you talk
to them think that certain people
learning is some sort of icy board with
lots of thoughts all over it and you see
these in logos a lot for AI companies i
but really you know deep learning is
just a sub as a subfield of machine
learning it's actually now your networks
is a subfield of machine learning and
then deep learning is a subfield of
neuro networks I new networks have been
around for a long time this is not new
stuff I you know people were working on
this stuff back in the 1980s and even
before then for certain you know certain
models but suddenly it's really only
become viable in the last eight years or
so because of one the amount of data
that we've got that these things require
to learn and also to more probably more
importantly the amount of compute that
they need to learn so you know as Chris
was showing you in the last talk you
know to do some of these big models you
need an extreme amount of compute now
you shouldn't let that discourage you
when you're starting out because
nowadays actually just with your laptop
you can build models that were
impossible to build sort of can 15 20
years ago right so it's it's all
relative is my point in that um the
other thing that's probably you know
making deep learning so famous is it's
pretty much every breakthrough that
you're seeing also and the majority of
breakthroughs you're seeing in a
and AI products really it's deep
learning at the back end of that whether
you're talking about something like
alphago whether you're talking about
self-driving with you talk all these
things are actually using mostly deep
learning to do this stuff so when we
talk about deep why do we use the word
deep so here's a model called inception
this deception version 3 so this is this
is quite a famous model I ate one I
it won the imagenet competition you a
few years back certainly I as it was
it's sort of like one of the stock
standard models that you'll find around
Google's to this day uses this for a lot
of things in fact I would suspected a
lot of those pre-made api's not Auto ml
but the pre-made ones are using you know
inception b3i now when we talk about
deep we're talking about the number of
layers this way in this case so on the
left here we've got the the inputs on
the right we've got the outputs and you
can see we're doing each of those little
sort of your modules that you're seeing
there is doing a bunch of calculations I
and to do this you really have to run it
on something like GPUs to give you an
example I've gotten I think this is like
2014-2015 this model came out I when it
first came out it took Google probably
around about it would cost them about
thirty thousand dollars to train the
model for just the amount of compute and
power and stuff like that to do it now
with the G we're seeing such an
acceleration in GPUs and stuff like that
if you've got a decent GPU card you
could probably train this at home over
the period of a few days you know to a
week or so so what can deep learning do
I you know I I sort of at you that you
should take a project and go for the
project so let's look at some of the
things you can do so you can do
classification and if you look at this
picture some of these are two hours some
of these are muffins right now I it
turns out that actually this is a very
simple classification task right for any
sort of computer vision algorithm can
swap this quite simply but it does sort
of show to you that you know often we
find that I you know using these things
for class
vacation of images is a big you know is
a big fact that in fact this is probably
the most common thing that you hear
people talk about if you think for those
of you who in here for the IOT talk
before a lot of what he was doing was
just classification there also the stock
standard classification things I but you
can go so much further this is where and
I would say so if you've heard some of
the talks over the past few days about
Auto ml Google's new product Auto ml in
many ways that is replacing sort of a
lot of the classic the need for you
writing your own classification models
because it could just do it so much
better and so much quicker but there are
so many other models that you know are
really important so segmentation models
these are used a lot for things like
self-driving and really what we're doing
in these kind of model since we're doing
classification but in a pixel level
we're classifying each pixel as is is
this a car is this a person is this a
traffic light I am more and more these
are starting to be used for a whole
bunch of different I you know different
sorts of products in industry and stuff
like that
we've got image captioning models so
we're basically you can train up an
algorithm to just look at a picture and
then write text about that picture and
write up you know a description of that
picture or write up something like that
I and you'll see that a lot of these
things are you know this this is an
example of where the model has basically
worked out that even though we can't see
that that the kite is connected to the
human the model is working out that the
probability is high that this human is
flying this kite so it can therefore
basically give it a caption I this is
also this kind of technology is also
being used in industry to basically talk
about you know eye spots on on LCD
screens and you know they're describing
problems you know in in products and
stuff like that we also have things like
generative models and this is where my
passion lies a lot I so these two things
that you're seeing here are things that
a models that I built early last year
the top one is what's called a super
resolution model it basically is that 8x
super resolution model you the picture
on the left is
in put the picture or in the middle
there is the predicted output and the
picture on the right is the real-world
output so you can see that it can it
learns pretty quickly to get it you know
pretty damn accurate I the one at the
bottom is a colorization model again the
picture on the left is the input the
picture in the middle is the prediction
the picture on the right is the output
in this case it's kind of interesting
because it you can see it doesn't get it
doesn't mess up with all the bad
lighting effects you can see in the one
on the right that's the lighting is very
hot and that's why you put that through
a yellow will change when it's able to
work out but you know okay this is what
it thinks it should look like we've also
got sequence models for doing things
like text and NLP and doing time series
analysis I fact we've got so many
different types of models so I could
just keep talking about all the
different models and keep going on we've
got new machine translation object
detection speech recognition QA systems
a whole bunch of these different things
in fact inside Google I this is an old
thing but pretty much I sort of the
middle of last year they were up to over
six thousand directories where Google
stores that we saw as its repose for its
code contain ten supply code or code
that was being used for machine learning
and deep learning I it's pretty much
being used in the majority of Google
products now if not almost all the
products so we talked about models you
know and this is something that I heard
Chris talk about you heard the previous
talk before Chris talk about what you
know me so everyone should you should be
wondering what what hell is this model
thing so I want to go through just some
of the basics of sort of what what the
building blocks of models and get you to
sort of think about you know knowing
what they are so the thing you start to
know what sort of questions to ask when
you're actually starting to learn this
stuff yourself so here's a very simple
model I am what were you can see we've
got some inputs which are going into a
number of hidden layers I and then we've
got an output and then we're basically
taking what's called a loss function
we're comparing the prediction to the
loss deciding okay how accurate is our
model and then we're using an optimizer
to base
we update the weights in those hidden
layers to then get better at learning
and this is where we talk about the
learning concepts going on basically
what's going on is that we're you know
we've got all these variables that are
weights and biases and we're adjusting
them so that as we pass inputs through
the model gets to learn something about
them and is able to make predictions so
when we're talking about the building
blocks the really the key things to
think about are your inputs and outputs
your architectures which I'll come back
and I'll talk about what you think about
those is like the design patterns or the
different types of connectivity inside
models I different types of losses and
loss functions and then optimizes these
are the four things that you will find
in pretty much every deep learning model
so once you know that these four things
exist
you're then just starting to think about
okay let me learn the different types of
those things so I'll sort of just go
through that with another graphic
quickly I if you see here we're passing
in the data and we've got labels that
we've at the start all right already
because we're training we passed the
data through the whole network it goes
through the hidden layers you see that
on the left there we've got weights and
biases that are basically being used for
the mathematical equations we then take
the loss of the network and work out
okay how accurate is this network and
then we basically use an optimizer to
update it now that loss we basically
compare what's coming out of the network
with the labels just see that okay are
we getting things right or wrong so
let's look at some of the types of you
know inputs that you can have I people
tend to think of you know things like
pictures or something like that but you
can actually have whole varieties of
different inputs so hopefully what I'm
trying to get through to you today is if
you're coding an app or if you're doing
some sort of you know web app even or
something like that you can start
thinking about okay what sort of inputs
could you then use to make some sort of
prediction that you want as an output so
we can have like lots of vectorized kind
of data
continuous data categorical data
obviously images I and if you think
about images really are just sort of
three channels maybe four if we have an
alpha channel I in what we call RGB
format
or BGR format all right we can also post
this audio by converting it to an image
by making it into spectra and then using
that spectra as a picture and running
you know a model on that picture we can
do the same with 3d medical scans of
being able to take you know I you know
mammography scans or something like that
and use the exact same sort of thing we
can do sequences so sequences will see a
lot for things like text models which
where we're basically looking at
sequences of either words or characters
speech I even through you know images
again can be sequences if it's we're
talking about video or something like
that then we come to the actual model
architectures and this is where you hear
a lot of the buzzwords you know sort of
talked about because what people are
talking about is you know what kind of
model is it and really currently they
fit into sort of three kinds of models
you have your fully connected models I
you have what's called convolution
models which basically pass a filter
across an image or something like that
and then and basically sort of do a
dimensionality reduction and play with
it and do number of different things
like that
then the third type with we have what's
called recurrent networks
so basically networks where they feed
into themselves I and they're useful for
things like time series stuff like a
audio you know processing like or you're
sort of things like your automatic
speech recognition things are using
things like that so the first type the
fully connected one a great example of
this is the tensorflow playground so I
encourage you just go go along to the
tenth school playground open it up and
start playing with it I you can't break
it that you know it's very simple you
can add layers to make the C so the
hidden layers is where we're defining
how deep the network is I and you can
basically play around with this well you
know I for hours trying to work out like
okay what's the right system to be able
to predict the different patterns and
they give you a number of different data
sets to play with
I lost as I kind of explained already I
think you know you're basically just
comparing your your predicted outputs
with your real outputs I optimizes
basically I don't want to go into too
much detail but we're trying to find
what's called a local minima for the
weights so the optimal point for those
weights so we therefore use optimization
functions and a variety of them which
basically try to look around and search
that space to find the right point or
the right value for each of those
weights in the actual network and then
eventually you get something like this
which is a convolutional neural network
that can predict the cat or a dog and
you can see that you know you should get
a look at this model now and understand
this right there okay the input layer is
the image right each one of the pixels
that is going in there the output layer
is predicting either cat or dog so
that's why we've only got two neurons
that right at the end I and the other
ones at the hidden layers as we go
through them so one of the big things
that I get a lot of people ask me about
is all the math that you need to learn
for this stuff so yes if you are gonna
sort of go deeper into it and start to
you know get more involved you're gonna
have to learn some math right I that
said you can already get away with so
many things without knowing the math so
don't be intimidated it's more like I
would say for most people it's better to
just go along without worrying too much
about the math learn how to build stuff
and at some point you're gonna start
wondering gee I wonder how this
particular part works and then you'll
want to learn a little bit of the math
to understand what's actually going on
in the code there or that kind of thing
so I put down some of the things there
that you can do I've also put a link
back to a video that will explain back
propagation quite easy I don't have time
to go there today I programming
languages a lot of people ask me about
programming languages okay yes you can
build neural networks in any programming
language but really there's only one
language that counts nowadays right
which is Python so if you're gonna be
you know building something for the
cloud
something like that you definitely want
to do it in Python even if you're
building a model that you're gonna then
deploy to something like tensorflow
liked or to core ml for apples
you know apples mobile you know neural
network models and stuff like that
you're gonna build those models in
Python and then you're gonna export out
the model and it will get converted into
the local format so you definitely want
to learn Python the cool thing is Python
is a great language and it's very simple
to learn oh do we have Python
programmers in the room yes okay
agreeing it's very simple syntax is very
easy to read so much so that when we
when we do our developer course for the
deep learning for the people who don't
know Python but are already coders we
literally just give them this one video
it's a one-hour video that teaches you
Python in one one hour and if you can
code another language reasonably well
you can go through that that entire
video and pretty much walk out
understanding all you need to know about
Python for this kind of thing Elise the
other thing is okay frameworks um a lot
of people ask me about frameworks and
there are a lot of different frameworks
and this has been one of the challenging
things for sure I you've got you know it
certainly tends to flow is one of the
biggest frameworks today you've got PI
torches we're coming on very strong
you've got MX net from AWS you've got
CMT Kay from Microsoft the cool thing is
this one in the middle is Karis and
Karis basically is a higher level
abstraction for deep learning which can
run on pretty much all of these
frameworks so I would you know I
basically say to anyone who wants to
start out start out with terrace it's
very simple for you to get started I
there's you know like I said if there's
a separate version that you can pick the
back end or you can actually use carrots
that is built into tensorflow I the cool
thing with carrots is that you have
access to a lot of pre-built and
pre-trained models so you can just
download those very simply I like
Christmas tree showing you in some of
his code I think they you using vgg 16
or something like that or one of the
models is something
you will doing a prebuilt model it's
very simple to basically load those
models and you're then basically getting
all the work that other people did in
building those models and you can use it
straight out of the you know straight
out of the box
you basically just change it for one of
the inputs you want to use whatever
outputs and then go for it
the other cool reason I think Terrace is
really worth checking out I is that
pretty much now because Kaos has been
around for a few years there's almost
examples of any type of model that you
want in Kerris on github so if you're
not sure how to build something you can
basically just go onto github do a
search for carers Plus you know image
object detection or something like that
and you'll find something that someone
has probably built already often in in
the actual you know in the actual
carrots repo itself under examples that
you can mentally use so I just quickly
I'm going to show you a very quick
example of terrace alright okay so for
those of you who don't know what I'm
using here is Jupiter notebooks Jupiter
notebooks is a great way to run Python
code it's very simple it allows you to
see the output of each cell as you run
it I and what I'm doing here I've just
got a bunch of input it imports to
basically import some libraries and
stuff like that I'm using
caris and I'm using tensorflow as the
backend on in this case I actually let
me go to the what I want to show you
guys I and here I'm basically importing
a data set very simply and what we're
going to predict is if you can't see it
this is basically this is basically an
image of a handwritten digit it's quite
famous data set called M NIST here's
some examples of the eats you were
actually plugging them out so you can
see these are basically just handwritten
images there's 70,000 of them in this
data set and which one we're going to
try and classify them between 0 to 9 so
I put a bit of lit you know a little bit
of sort of theorem here to explain some
of the things what is a tensor I you
know tensors are just the different
shapes for those of you who
I have never come across this before
think of them as sort of
multi-dimensional arrays is one of the
ways that you can sort of think of them
I and then you can see that in this case
basically our images are 28 by 28 pixels
and it's only one channel because it's
just black and white all right so we've
got a grayscale image there but then we
have like batches of them we actually
have 70,000 of them so we've got 70,000
deep so then we want to basically build
so here I'm importing them you can
basically see I'm setting them up to two
basically this is what's called one hot
in coding where I'm telling the model
that okay this is how I want you to
predict each of these digits so show me
by you know showing me ten numbers and
then put a one on the one that relates
to this number okay the key thing is but
I want to show you is this so this is
the entire code for building this model
it's literally with one line we define
that we're building a sequential model
we then add in one hidden layer just
like we would intensive our program
where we press plus and add in a hidden
layer we tell it basically I you know
how many so I've sort of set these up
before how many neurons we want to have
in each of these hidden layers we go
through we add it so we've got you know
two hidden layers then we've got an
output layer cool thing with terrace
very simply we can check out what our
model looks like just by doing dot
summary and we can see that this is the
shape of our model this is the number of
parameters that we're using so what
Kerris has done is worked out based on
the amount of neurons that we're using
how many weights and how many biases do
we need for each of these layers and you
had you haven't have to write the code
for any of this this is already done for
you I then we basically compile the
model by telling it what kind of lost
function remember I talked about lost
functions or one of the four things
that's really important and the other
thing I talk about is the optimizers
what kind of optimizer is really
important so we're basically telling it
that okay we want to use a loss function
called character categorical cross
entropy I am we're going to use an OP
miser caustic a stochastic gradient
descent in this case I and we're gonna
basically it you know get it to work on
accuracy
so we're basically optimizing for it to
get the highest score possible of
predicting these numbers we can then
basically just train it by doing this so
we basically just fit the model so we're
basically passing in both at the start
we're passing in those images we're
passing in the labels for what those
images are I and we've got a few things
there like epochs which is the number of
times through we want to do this we're
gonna do two times through I and then
we're gonna validate so I didn't have
time to explain the whole concept in
machine learning that you you never
validate on the material that you
actually trained on you keep a separate
data set for validation so we've got a
separate data set here that we're gonna
validate on and can see we run the model
and very quickly I we're up to 94%
accuracy with just a very simple model I
and you know probably 20 years ago this
would have been state of the art I we
can then even sort of take it to the
next step and make it even I you know
even further I by by making a
convolutional network so the one I just
showed you there was what we call a
fully fully connected network by making
in a convolutional network again the
model is just slightly a little bit bit
more complicated but you can see it's
it's not many lines of code at all i
again showing you what the the model
actually looks like the you know
compiling the model and then training
the model and here you know with that
with not that long
we're up to sort of 99% accuracy on this
data set and this is training from
scratch if we were using something like
a premade model we could actually train
it much quicker and we could do much
more advanced images and stuff like that
and it would still be able to do it
really quickly please this one I
deliberately ran through on my laptop
before to show you sort of like it's not
going to take forever on a laptop it's
taking sort of you know about two
minutes or something on on a CPU on a
GPU this will take that get to three
seconds for a pork right it's much much
quicker we can see this is you know we
can get some
you see and sort of see like what's
going on now model okay where I will go
back to finish up so if you are
interested in doing you know in learning
more of this sort of stuff these are
some books that you should definitely
check out I say you know the one on the
left is probably the most difficult so
start with one and eat with either the
other two first I in fact the book on
the right there by Francois gelee
Francois Sheila is the creator of
carrots so that book actually goes
through everything using carrots and
explaining to you how to do it and this
is something you can just sort of do as
of you know as a passion project in a
month you can get through that book and
learn all the key concepts for deep
learning if you're looking for courses I
definitely you know you it's worth
checking out Andrew ends course Jeremy
Howard has a good course at faster AI
Geoffrey Hinton has a course which is
somewhat out of date now but it's still
worth going through because his is
pretty much one of the key founders of I
deep learning and neural networks and
also Stanford has numerous courses
online if you want to come in person and
do a course I this is a course we're
gonna be doing in Singapore I I think
it's three weeks from today the 14th of
April so if it's something that you're
interested come along the whole idea
with this course is that we want people
to bring projects along and we're gonna
start you know going through and the
whole idea with this course is that you
should be able to build a basic project
by the end of the three nights we did
this once before where we just did
everything in one day and realize the
problem with that was that people went
home tried a lot of stuff out more more
stuff out and realize they had all these
questions so we've now added like you
know evening sessions to basically
answer questions and go through and help
people who are you know not
understanding certain parts of it um
okay just to sort of wrap up I would say
have a clear application of what you
want to build I realize that this field
is too big to know everything I even for
people who are professional researchers
in it I can tell you the
you know having been at the had it had a
paper at nips conference you know last
year and talking to a lot of
professionals people specialized right
so don't try to learn everything
yourself because you're going to get
totally overwhelmed another thing I
would say is if you don't understand one
person's explanation for something find
someone else's this material can often
be very difficult to explain I and often
you know people tend to click with one
explanation versus another explanation
both of which might be you know quite
valid ways to explain something again go
back to the basics it's all about just
the i/o the connectivity patterns your
losses your optimizers uh any inclusion
I'd say you know everyone who succeeds
learns deep learning in a different way
but everyone who fails fails in the same
way they give up so it's not that
difficult if you're prepared to put the
time in and and do it it's something
that you can certainly do and I
encourage you to do it thank you
[Applause]